foreign
guys welcome back to flickers of fear so
for today's movie we're going to a
remote forest in Ireland for a movie
called The Hallow now this was
originally called the woods I saw it
like several years ago uh at a
recommendation and I just noticed as of
this recording which is in September of
2023 that shutter had just added it so I
thought it was a good time to kind of
revisit my thoughts on it
so this had its Premiere in 2015 at
Sundance and this was the directorial
debut of Colin Hart Korean Hardy rather
sorry
um he would actually later go on to
direct the nun uh the 2018 entry into
The Conjuring Universe uh which you know
the sequel of that just came out
recently which I haven't seen I've seen
the first one which was okay uh but I
haven't seen the second one yet
so the hollow I feel like okay so it's
like a pretty straightforward horror
movie it's essentially a simple family
in a secluded Farmhouse attacked by
creatures kind of movie and I'm kind of
gonna say picture the evil dead but
without the humor or the wackiness and
with maybe like evil Irish fairies
instead of demons and rapey trees and
you're kind of gonna get the gist of the
ballpark of where this movie is at so
this movie is following a character
named Adam who's played by Joseph mall I
think is how you pronounce his last name
he's was on Game of Thrones
um and his wife Claire and their baby
son whose name is Finn and they move out
to this kind of like spooky rundown
farmhouse in out in the Irish wilderness
So Adam his job is the reason that he's
out there he's a conservationist like
tree scientist type of guy and he's been
sent out there to assess the trees that
are going to be cut down for some
pending development I guess
so because of this uh he's not really a
big hit with the locals as you can
imagine because the locals not only like
don't want the forest that actually
provides a lot a large part of their
livelihood to be cut down but also
because they actually do genuinely
believe in these kind of like creepy
beasties uh that live out in the woods
and they don't want these you know
creatures to become pissed off and start
coming out to
steel babies which is apparently
something that they are uh reputed to do
particularly antagonistic in this regard
is a neighbor of theirs whose name is
comb Donnelly and he just keeps like
turning up at the family's house to
threaten them
um and kind of like warn them about the
dangers of like all these creatures in
the woods that they're antagonizing and
maybe they need to stop it obviously
though Adam is very skeptical of all of
this
um you know and he just thinks a bunch
of it is like mythological nonsense
obviously as you would probably but
even he has to admit there's something
kind of weird going on in the woods
right um like something flies through
the window of the house one night he
sees hints of kind of like unidentified
animals like lurking out in the trees
and the area seems to be pervaded by
this weird black goo that when he kind
of takes some samples of it and
investigates it like you know in a
scientific sort of way it kind of
resembles this fungus that can
infiltrate a you know a creature's
nervous system uh you know whatever the
host organism is and can influence Its
Behavior which is a real thing so that's
kind of what they're going with in this
movie so there's a point in the story
like Adam and Finn the baby they get
attacked while they're in their car by
this creature which they don't show but
it leaves like this huge claw Mark like
across the driver's side door which I
kind of liked I kind of like that they
didn't show it it just came like
implication now Claire the wife she
thinks yeah as you would probably we
should get out of here because this is
you know not not looking like a good
situation
but naturally
um Adam being a dude he's going to uh
not be intimidated by what he believes
at first he doesn't believe this is a
real
animal or a real creature that is
threatening them he believes that it's
the other locals that are trying to get
rid of them by doing like some
Scooby-Doo [__] you know what I mean
like they're trying to just prank them
you know what I'm saying like
maliciously however from then on
the situation starts getting worse and
worse Adam gets uh spoiler alert taken
over by this fungus uh and the baby Finn
ends up getting taken by whatever these
creatures are now this was actually my
favorite part of the movie
um because the monsters were kind of
like gooey and everything they made off
with the baby like Claire actually
chased them and seemingly rescued the
baby from the swamp nearby and then
returned to the house
but then you know what you're led to
assume is like a partially possessed
atom starts insisting well the baby
isn't really theirs he's like a
changeling so there was a lot of really
good tension like in this part of the
movie as you who's watching it
um you're kind of left to wonder whether
the baby really had been replaced or
whether Adam who had been kind of taken
over by the fungus as you're led to
assume is
you know if the fungus is making Adam
see things that way like he he's seeing
things like not really the way they are
so um I'm gonna say to you that like the
changeling baby like at least the way he
perceived it looked really really good
it was like really really spooky and I
really really dug that uh that visual so
gonna say overall
um I've seen this a couple times uh you
know over the years since it came out
I found this a pretty enjoyable but not
like a super compelling flick and it's
hard for me to put my finger on why
exactly that might be it had some great
Gore it had some great uh practical
effects uh had some good like you know
Lucio full chi-esque like eye trauma
which I I always enjoy
um there were you know a few scenes of
like real effective like creepiness like
it was like really spooky or like really
creepy
but I have to say that I felt like I
wasn't
involved enough with the characters to
really be rooting for them you know what
I'm saying so the whole thing
fell a little flat for me and that you
know that might be just my experience
I'm not really sure if that you know
translates across the board I just
couldn't really get into the characters
to an extent I was like oh [__] like I
didn't want bad [__] to happen to them
like I couldn't really connect with them
like in a human kind of way they just
seemed kind of I don't know kind of like
generic I guess
um also while I liked the overall
concept of this movie I do kind of feel
like they should have
given more of a distinctive
Flair to the movie based around the
Irish folklore like if that's the way
that you're gonna go that these are kind
of like these
you know kind of like baby sealing
fairies like out in the woods that are
you know obviously gonna steal your kids
and [__] like that and like replace them
with changelings I kind of feel like you
should lean really hard into that
because there's a lot of movies that are
you know Cabin in the Woods type movies
it's like you know we're stuck in this
cabin there's like all these whatever
beasties like outside and it's like you
know so I kind of feel like they should
have like distinguished it a little bit
more from like other ones
um because this one I don't think they
did that enough so I kind of feel like
it came off as a little bit of a
run-in-the-mill cabin in the woods type
movie it's just like you know what I
mean it could have been like anything
out there and I feel like they should
have like really played up the Irish
folklore aspect of it a little bit more
in my opinion I'm just saying I mean
this was elevated by the acting which is
very good and the Eerie setting of it
and the look at the monsters which I
thought was like really really cool I'm
gonna say like okay I found this out
while I was researching this movie
apparently this movie was originally
pitched as Straw Dogs meets
pans Labyrinth which
I don't
like I'm not [__] I just don't see
it I don't see it
um it's not fantasy enough based to be
anything like Pan's Labyrinth and it's
not near brutal enough to be anything
like Straw Dogs
um so
I don't know I I kind of get where they
were going with that but I don't know if
they necessarily achieve that like like
I said to me it seemed kind of like the
evil dead but not funny
uh and like not and like more restrained
you know what I mean it kind of came
across like a cabin in the woods type
there's a monster in the woods type of
[__] it kind of came across like that so
I don't know I kind of feel like had
this been more like Pan's Labyrinth I
probably would have dug it a lot more
than I actually ended up digging it you
know what I'm saying now in the movie's
defense I will admit that I watched this
when I was really really tired so
it could be that like my exhaustion or
whatever kind of claded my judgment made
me more impatient or maybe more
disengaged than I would have been
normally I'm not really sure how that
you know how that played out I'm gonna
say like so I'm not gonna go too far in
that direction like I said I've seen it
a couple times like I I gave it another
watch to see if I was just and I still
was like I liked it but I didn't love it
you know what I mean it just didn't I
don't know it just didn't hit
like it's a good movie but it's not a
great movie it wasn't like super
memorable but it's a decent watch I will
say that so if you're into like a
nominally
Irish fairy tale take on the evil dead
maybe but not like zany or anything like
that so don't think it's like it's not a
horror comedy or anything like that but
it's just kind of like a cabin in the
woods type thing but with an Irish folk
tale kind of like veneer to it if you're
into that if that sounds cool then
you know then maybe like give it a give
it a whirl because it is on shutter at
this moment and so you might really dig
it but like I said I liked it well
enough but it didn't really stand out to
me a great deal
even after the second watch but you know
your mileage may vary a lot of people
really did seem to like it but you know
it for me it was just kind of like
middle of the road but you might really
dig it so check it out if that sounds
like your cup of tea so that will do it
for this flickers of here hope you guys
enjoyed it please remember to like share
subscribe comment and all of that good
stuff and I will see you guys again on
the next one bye